it's you don't know about my ways
but gain a lot of money and we gotta go
and suck hold up and about them it's
about you it's about people who love
movies by people who love movies and
watch them shop so for a comic at you
know the ones at the earths person you
know that I can't get in
well I'm gonna do is I'm gonna bring it
all comes to Frogtown back no I ain't
doing that you know what you gotta do
but you gotta check them out Rowdy Roddy
Piper you review for you by you welcome
to the first ever you reviewers awards
the awards show created for you by
people like you on tonight's show some
of the most popular reviewers as well as
up-and-comers band together for an award
show for you some of the you reviewers
you will see tonight Gavin dad
Revolution reviews Mike from the lated
media
Ezra's huge reviews the freaking film
critic bright eyes big lashes Chris
Stockman Tom chattel bash fury of the
film fan celebrity appearances by singer
and actress bonnie somerville from FX's
hit show the leaked Steve Rannazzisi
from Battlestar Galactica 24 and CSI
Katee Sackhoff which one of your
favorites will win it's all tonight on
the first you reviewers award
trust me Chris Nolan did not get screwed
on this show and now your hosts the man
with the greatest hair on the Internet
Jeremy John's and two guys who don't own
a suit from schmoes know the schmoes
thank you to rowdy roddy piper for being
the soft-spoken individual that we all
remember you for that was badass so
thank you all for coming and I welcome
you to the first-ever and annual you
reviewers Movie Awards the movie awards
show for you by people like you yes I'm
here representing the common normal
everyday film fan in a three-piece or
these teepees why it seemed a good idea
I'm sure some of you are saying what's
the point of this why knew it and I
answer because as you've noticed and
we've certainly noticed award shows out
there aren't for people like us
therefore really pretentious snobby
stuffy people who in order to be part of
an award show you have to get the
quadruped of PhDs from Harvard Stanford
an overrated foot yes we know movies you
know only baloney for instance in a
movie when there's a gun don't shoot it
to talk about it makes for a better
movie you wouldn't know that they're
common folk yeah and that's just not fun
that's not relatable I personally don't
relate to it if you don't either this is
your show and it's a show that I'm not
doing alone so I'd like to welcome and
introduce my co-host two of the coolest
normal chill dudes out there on YouTube
Christian and Mark the schmoes from
schmoes no give them a hand thank you I
am a valet at the Red Lobster
okay so Jeremy broke it down for you
we'll break it down as well love to your
viewers Awards the reason we're doing
this is because it's not so much I know
there's a bunch of reviews a bunch of
videos that came out basically saying oh
they're doing this because
snub than they do want to just you know
this one make there only put all the
snub people in it it's not really why we
did it yeah we don't really care that
much about who got snuff they're all
rich right but it was more or less like
we want to make sure that you guys have
like everyone has a say everybody that's
fun we want to kind of just join
together do our own thing and so we can
you just feel like you're all
everyone shut out Christian I believe
the word is political oh you know you
gotta be somebody to get into the
Academy right because yeah if you have a
pulse and a webcam welcome to the show
so now you know you know why we're doing
it what the show is all about what
you're in for
I think you're gonna have fun so let's
get this ball rolling our first awards
actually a you reviewers exclusive and
that is most underrated film because
they came we saw they went but they're
still good they're worth mentioning even
worth giving in Ward 2 right special
award created just for the you reviewers
and we're gonna have our first
presenters and we love these two I got a
kick out of them I really do most of
mine doesn't seem like he wasn't wants
to be there but as long as he has a
drink in his hand he's happy with it and
he's gonna tell you exactly what he
thinks I'm of course talking about dad
yeah you know some people used to drag
their dads out to play baseball with him
or take them fishing gaff drugs our dad
around to your movie prick you and now
she driving the awards show but dad you
look great you got a sceptre of brandy a
bowtie present an award with us without
any further ado Gavin dad and on a side
note dad from Gavin dad insisted that
there should have been a red carpet at
this event but sadly Lindsay Lohan was
busy most underrated film
hi it's Gabe and dad we're here to
present the you reviewer award for most
underrated film you're not going to get
that at the Oscars dad what are the
nominees the nominees are shutter
island' Scott Pilgrim V's the world
person versus thank you Scott Pilgrim
vs. the world the American happens to be
one of my favorites nobody else's the
nominee oh yeah I know it is
legend of the guardians the owls go and
kick ass I like guys who did the you
reviewers and Gabriel who did they pick
your reviewer winner of most underrated
film of 2010 is Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world
here's to Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
good take your viewers
I think it was just I'm okay with that
one yeah you know it's kind of fitting
that we kick off a movie review show on
the web with Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
a lot of young people really got into
you you young people got into the
videogames film and I have a feeling
that's not gonna be the last time we
hear from mr. pilgrim no I think we're
gonna hear his name quite often and
there you go Scott Pilgrim fill in the
love proof positive that an academy
should not be run by a bunch of
middle-aged women that still used the
phrase video games will rot your brain
because they won't not shows way more
funner issed
if the Academy Awards gives a shout-out
to Scott Pilgrim in any way shape or
form they're officially ripping us off
just saying you're here to hear first
party free wicked stuff yeah this
happened we're officially out of suits
sore back in our comfort zone and back
with you guys and letting you guys know
that the next award is going to be for
Best Screenplay original or adapted
alright so as we've all seen firsthand
if you have a really interesting premise
and some really solid actors you can't
do much with that if you have a crappy
script otherwise your movies gonna begin
with phantom and end with menace how do
you screw that up unacceptable and here
to announce the winner for Best
Screenplay adapted or original is our
pal the revolution reviews eclectus name
stands for a revolution his revolution
reviews and he's gonna be presenting our
next award of Best Screenplay adapter
original the British are coming
the screenplay and I'm here to bring you
the you reviewers Award for Best
Screenplay original or adapted the
nominees are Christopher Nolan for
inception any boil for 127 hours Aaron
Sorkin for the social network I go
aren't for Toy Story 3 and David Seidler
for The King's Speech for the past
couple years there's been a huge scuffle
over writers not thinking they get what
they deserve so let's hear it for them
you literally have no idea how much fun
I have with that quite shameful amount
so the Award for Best Screenplay
original or adapted from the you
reviewers goes to run low please
oh there I go again there's actually
nothing right not here this social
network kill us at Corey Feldman isn't
it a little put together Corey Feldman
can't hand himself in public well
talking about Fridays ever seen Goonies
and there you go folks the winner for
Best Screenplay the movie about the
Facebook Empire the social network which
is better than the movie that we're
gonna make about MySpace called good job
you just your computer with
viruses while trying to chase down - you
pedophile yeah social network
probably a bit better
as for the social network a justified
win right here the movie deals with the
building of Facebook without making it
about Facebook character-based strong
dialog good conflict all around good
movie if you hate Facebook watch the
movie you'll still like it I believe
that these are the Oscars are trying to
be different from us right and their
social network again if you're giving it
if you're giving an award for Best
Screenplay or for screenplay with the
most words per page in it
either way social network is gonna win
there's a lot of talking so you should
probably go to Screenplay award and who
says animations are just for kids 2010
was the year of animations and if you
didn't like at least one nominee in this
next category maybe even a few that
didn't make it get your soul back from
that guy seriously this is of course the
best animated film there are a lot of
great animation this this year and I
think that the you reviewers have
nominated some great films and to tell
us about such films an up-and-coming
really good you reviewer he's one of my
favorites and here to present the winner
for Best Animated Film is the YouTube
up-and-comer the freaking critic of film
Victor I always had a cool name like
Victor I really do Jeremy you don't get
chased with a name like Jeremy Victor
though you're said best animated film
there are the nominations for best
animated film 122 Despicable Me 3 my How
to Train Your Dragon and this
prestigious award goes to attitude that
kids still my shirt is that like a blue
version of this shirt of circus great
taste and wardrobe buddy and Toy Story 3
who could have called that certainly not
me
that is the most shocking thing I've
heard since Scott Pilgrim when he most
underrated movie was really good but
again if you got woody and he got Buzz
Lightyear in a good story and that pain
is people bear you can't not give it an
award that's right so I mean I think
again just proving the fact that we
don't have to be different everything
it's just another accolade that Toy
Story 3 should get it stop comparing
yourself to the Oscars you're doing fine
on your own you know it makes you feel
any better these videos have you been
released yet
we're already higher rated than the
Golden Globes but Toy Stores I mean come
on how can that not win it had
excitement nostalgia emotion it may
grown men weep let them know it's okay
Roddy Piper though I don't know if he
wept in Toy Story 3 another word from
the lovely and multi talented singer and
actress bonnie somerville I'm not even
multi-talented I like do two things in
my life YouTube and make Top Ramen hi
I'm Bonnie sorry though you might know
me from such shows as friends Mona from
friends maybe maybe if you did not blink
you might have might have seen how I
show cashmere mafia I played a lesbian
that was a big hit and a couple of other
TV shows I'm an actress and I love
movies I love television and I love
schmoes know because they are two
regular dudes that review movies the way
I watch
which is basically to criticize him rip
everyone to shreds because I wish I was
in Morse but no that's the whole thing I
heard about the you reviewers Awards
thought it was an awesome idea because
let's face it most reviewers suck and
our fellowship and/or pompous and or
talk about things that you don't really
care about most movie reviewers are like
talking about things you don't really
want to know don't make any sense to me
there's serious then you have you guys
like the schmoes that I love like we're
gonna remove okay let's cool let's have
a pizza whatever that's cool too these
are the guys that I appreciate so what I
heard about these awards I thought what
a great idea to have normal people like
you giving awards to movies that you
actually like that you actually care
about not you know subtitled films that
are like all the rage or movies
but real movies that you watch and real
reviews that you can appreciate that you
might say yourself that was a great idea
thank you very much for the kind words
bonnie somerville you are a badass and
talented and hot that's right
professional here on the you reviewers
Movie Awards but that's our show that's
episode one of four there's a lot more
to come thank you all for watching we
want to make this a big deal we want to
choke out every douchebag that ever
thought that there will be blood had a
good soundtrack so tell your friends
tell your mom tell your teachers
teachers might hate the show tell your
friends though thank you to the schmoes
from schmoes know for co-hosting with me
be sure to subscribe to the schmoes so
you get episode 2 i'll put an annotation
right there that's right you want to see
episode 2 of the show it'll be on their
channel I get one they get to like it 3
they get for every co-host gets a piece
that's how we do it here you can check
out Bonnie Somerville's music on iTunes
I put a link below in the underbar there
check it out listen to it very talented
and awesomely genius and smart cuz she
came up in this show and thank you to
the Rowdy Roddy Piper for coming on the
show I had your action figure buddy so
that was badass
so remember subscribe to the schmoes for
the next part of the show and come back
here for part three there's three more
parts to come so the fun ain't over yet